Let's update
the testInsertReadDb test
to use the WeatherProvider
to get the weather query.
We'll start by changing the name
to testInsertReadProvider.
So, all we need to do
is take this db query
and replace it with
the equivalent content provider one,
which gets the ContentResolver,
and then queries the CONTENT_URI.
Now, the ContentProvider one
doesn't take a few of these parameters.
For example, it doesn't take TABLE_NAME,
because that's implied by the URI,
nor does it support group by.
The rest of it should work pretty well.
Now let's run the test
and verify that it passes.
(silence)
And the test still passes.
(laughing) Again, it's very easy
to substitute out something
that calls directly to the database
with a content provider.